hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
latrell's nanotechnology enabled
biomarker quantification for early
disease detection presented by Tony who
he is an associate professor at the
Biodesign Institute at Arizona State
University's Virginia G Piper Center
I am Marjorie Torres elaborate and I'll
be your moderator for today's bet we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by elaborate
labyrinth is the winning scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and love
bars before we begin our tour I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen what answers
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and that's offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Tony who I will now turn the
presentation over to him
hello everyone I'm Tony who and today
I'm going to introduce how our
nanotechnology serve the biomarker
discovery and the quantification for
disease diagnosis and the case we like
to present is the quantification of our
circulating micro bacterial antigens
were right hip TB diagnosis and
real-time treatment monitoring so TB is
very odd business and this is like it is
showing the current of fact 40 beating
this and it's a still the very serious
of public health problems and affecting
when cert population in the world and in
China and India this number increased to
the 45% and is still the top killer of
HIV infected patients and also there's
no no there's no technology or early
detection of TV so what's the problem of
for TB diagnosis and we have a hundreds
of technology on the market it's always
rely on the similar concept the people
always trying to isolate bacterial first
and for example like the bacterial
culture master it was still the gold
standard but as such master days are so
time-consuming it can last of six to
eight weeks to cut result and but a
still super it's offer very low
sensitivity in the certain patient
population for example like extra
pulmonary TB and HIV in back to the
patient and also the pediatric patients
not only have a gene expert but they
still rely on the similar concept
they're trying to capture the profile
the DNA from the sputum samples is
pretty fast but I still cannot reach the
very high sensitivity in the extra
pulmonary TB impacted operations and
another problem is it cannot offer the
quantitative result because the Gina
expert cannot identify
life were fight bacteria so dr. likely
have a blood test so that we have the
blood test and we can overcome the
problem if the patient is pulmonary TB
were extra pulmonary TB and we have the
address but a grocer is like indirectly
testing is testing the human immunology
response so cannot be be quenched cannot
have differential night the activity
between there so from the latent he
being in fractions so that's kind of
useless test for ro China and India
because we have a huge population there
impacted by TB and none of them can
offer the quantitative result which is
so important to track the treatment
efficacy for those patients or treatment
and e TB treatment so here is the
highest Sri Hines the priority for TB
diagnosis the first one can we have a
reputed diagnosis independent of a
bacterial isolation which means culture
rate we don't have to use a sputum
culture and a second one can we capture
something you know from nice building
samples for example like a blood or
urine and a third one most important can
we have a master it can which that can
offer quantitative result in attracting
the treatment response because now we
have a lot of drug-resistant TB so so
our hypothesis is is showing in this a
slight and we're trying to capture the
antigen secret from MTV directly and
then we profile the antigen from the
blood sample so we expect that the
quantification of the antigen can offer
the rapid
result for diagnosis and also the
treatment efficacy so the antigen we
seen act is well known
biomarkers inhibit field and the people
has a studied these two biomarkers
allowed in the cultural studies and one
is such the EpiPen and the other one is
ISA 6 so we expected to capture them and
offer the direct evidence were active
for activity B D this and when we start
in 2013 and we spend a year to capture
this to my to antigens directly from the
human blood samples because the typical
he is a very of we're so they are in the
very low concentration in the blood so
we had to give up the very sensitive
technology to capture these two antigens
and even we capture these antigens the
new problem is it's not a very specific
to MTB because the other non-tuberculous
mycobacterial there's several spaces
also sacred the homogeneous a if you can
and isa sakes so in another word if we
want to use the immuno immuno based IC
to profile the circuit and in the in so
six you cannot make sure you cannot
confirm the bacteria is is MTB were and
here so yam is a still a huge problem in
the u.s. because most HIV infected
patients fear they can be very easy to
become impacted by ndm so to address
this the problem and we start focusing
on the protect my team or a mutant and
the es essex and we're trying to locate
the MTB specific peptide or for each
antigen as our new biomarkers so through
the extensive search on the database and
eventually we captured two antigens
highly specific to an tv-14 circuit in
and at the other one is for esau 6 so
since we have the new biomarker and we
specially optimized other technology to
maximize the signal for this
- peptide on the spectrum so the reading
out we see Magda is mass back and to
reach the very high sensitivity of this
to mass at you antigen peptide we
designed the new nanoparticles so here
this is mite is showing how this method
works at first we have a human sample so
we do a quick microwave assistant
digestion so once you have does only
take a 20 minutes
so once you'd have a digest to the human
solution and you mixed with a banana
particle an oven and a particle is
silicon porous nano disc so the
structure is it's a sitting Perico the
diameter is around a 2 micron meter and
on this day on this nanoparticle we have
hundreds were hundreds of the Nano or
are made so that each nanopore is around
a 30 to 30 nanometer so on an I know
poor and we conjugate anybody so the
power is the structure offered in larger
surface area which can allow us to
conjugate a lot of the net anybody so in
the first step when we just mix the
nanoparticles or nano days ago is that
digested human sample and they can
efficiently enrich your target prep
tight then without illusion which is
directly spike nanoparticle on a target
of the body mass back so on the multi
mass back and when the laser in the
multi shooting on the particle and the
particle will perform the second
function which is called energy transfer
so they will transfer the energy
received from a laser to your peptide
under light to your peptide target so
the bottom to the nice back of profile
is showing the comparison between the
master with and without using the
nanoparticles
the difference is a pretty upwards and
for the EpiPen peptide you can tell the
the sensitivity the different the
sensitivity is a 72 times
so the next light and we're trying since
with the reading out is a mess back so
we have a chance to set up absolute
quantification of mazzard to label the
antigen in the blood so we introduce the
isotropy labeled a peptide as the
standard and for each peptide target and
we established the very linear
calibration curve and the Pinal see here
is a showing that representative profile
of the target peptide and is a sort of a
label the peptide for a patient and I
can chose so like this is like and once
we have the message set up and we're
trying to validate this for this method
works with the communica samples and we
receive the first group of samples from
nih clinical centers and a collaborator
their contributors of 776 a pulmonary TB
and so and also the 19 extra power ETV
so the extra pulmonary TB is a very
difficult to diagnose by the current
technology because generally the
keynesian cannot capture the bacteria
from the sputum test so but here you can
check out with showing the very decent a
sensitivity in both pulmonary TB and
also the extra primary key B and we also
received a 96 in-house control
so here the specificity is the it's very
decent and we also tested the 14 ammonia
operations and so the our definition is
e our definition for the paucity of the
TV is either one of and attempt at kite
showing up and we would define this
patient as a positive so we shouldn't
see anything you know in the pneumonia
operations but here you can tell there's
two patients showing a very weak signal
and a base the current definition and we
have to at least to them as a past
positive so it's a job our specificity
specificity to 95
and then we also has the 24 nan chipper
closest mycobacterial so that's what
that's the that's the reason why we
wanna see magnapack tight as the
biomarker instead of the whole protein
of the antigen as a biomarker so we want
to be foreign aid that he might t be
from the other nine shibulata mantra
closest microbacterial and you can tell
in 24:9 chipra closest microbacterial
and there's no patients with showing the
signal for capt and in sussex apartheid
so the next we really might like to know
if this master that can't be originated
the active TB from the latent TB
infraction so we got us 31 lights on the
TV in factions and so our definition is
still we shouldn't see any singing of
invasive population but we see four of
the patients they're showing the very
weak signal and we have to list them as
the past past positive at this moment
but if you read it a reason to review
paper published on the nature and you
can find there's a like a statement it's
generally there's about five to ten
percent of latent TB infection in fact
it patient there at early phase of
activity be but we don't have any
mastered to your character them so we're
actually also looking for the
collaboration to allow us to task
if this IC is capable to capable to
pasture the active TB at early phase and
also we got more samples from the HIV
and the light and typically interactions
so we didn't act more false positive in
this in this group but we have to know
that HIV in fact the play for HIV
infected creations
active related to TB is extremely
difficult to diagnose with the current
technology and also we also have the
diabetes and the light in the TV cone
infected patients and that are
PT's is a huge public problem now not
only for China and erratic in countries
it's also for the u.s. so the Lightning
TV
in factions the diabetes and the light
and the TV : faction is a has been the
the hot topic for an IH so after the
testing the panicked study after the the
conducted a pilot study and we start a
more formal canonical validation
so we collaborate we collaborate with
another hospital they have us to recruit
like almost 1000 patients
so the based on the other type of nation
we exclude about 700 of them and so that
if you see the bottom and we have a 95
culture positive patients left and also
the 102 a quarter an active patient that
so for the gold standard you can tell in
this cohort the sensitivity is below 50%
and also we have a 96 lunch of the
closest individuals as the control so in
the into group contrapositive and cotton
active TB cases we have the different
number of a pulmonary and extra
pulmonary TB impacted patients so using
this cohort and we like to validate our
two hypothesis for this I see the number
one we like to see if IC can offer the
similar sensitivity in in both pulmonary
and extra pulmonary TB and in number two
we like to see of AIESEC offered a
similar sensitivity in in the culture
positive and in active cases so here is
the result or first were validating the
first hypothesis and so our performance
for this to pulmonary and extra primary
TB impacted patients and we can capture
147 one 167 patient
with pulmonary TB impacted patients so
the sensitivity is 88% is a show me on
the bottom line and if you look at our
performance in the extra primary TB
impacted patients in the 30 patients we
capture the 27 so the sensitivity is
about 90 percent so 80 80 percent 90
percent is a pretty similar so that's my
knee late our first hypothesis then we
look at the culture mackay of patients
which is a huge problem in the most
developing countries so in the 95 past
the culture positive patients we capture
the 87 and so the sensitivity is about a
92% and in the 102 culture negative
patients and we capture the 87 so they
said the sensitivity is 85% so it's not
there's no big difference for all I see
in these two groups so also cannot
validate the our second hypothesis then
we have actually we have we got a new
discovery so we know that HIV and TB
coming back to the patients we call them
Bubble Trouble in the TV diagnostic boot
because HIV infection cost a lot of the
problem for TB diagnosis is not a very
specific and is really hard to identify
to any us any signal using the chance to
x-ray and but our result actually are
all further burry the opposite symptoms
and phenomena list and we can be tact a
higher sensitive we can detect a higher
level of antigen from the blood of HIV
and that he be coming back to the
patients compared to HIV maggoty but tv+
patients so we can explain there's a
phenomenal as the immuno contrast and
because generally the wonderful when the
normal patients are the key being
infected and their immune system will by
twister will
vitaly's the bacterial and a cage of
them in the pulmonary system but for the
HIV patients your immune system crashed
so once they impacted by the by MTB so
the bacterial could be spray out quickly
so they cannot stay in the pulmonary
system but that that that practically
antigen more chance to blow into the
blood so the next one if we called HIV
TB who impacted patients as Bubble
Trouble and the pediatric TB patients is
tangentially its triple threat so it's
really hard they actually have all the
difficulty from the from the adult from
the TB diagnosis per adult and also for
Pediatrics once they gotta impact it the
develop and implement other activities
should be very fast so we are
fortunately about the while organized
the cohort from the pediatric patients
including the 1559 pediatric with PD
back to the patients and 208 controls
those controls could be their contact or
siblings so of the patients so in the 59
patients we capture but 352 quickly even
the some sample has been stored in the
freezer for 20 years and we can still
see that there's some signal either CIT
10 Orissa sakes apartheid and in their
lot and in the 208 control the
specificity we can reach these 95
percent so and we're to use our
quantification my search so we didn't
forget how we didn't forget the the
benefit of this quantification protocol
so we try to apply this method to
evaluate treatment that he be treatment
advocacy and at first we got support
from our Chinese collaborators and they
contribute us to send but the patients
from the to the samples from two
patients
and they're all collected at baseline
and also one about one week after the
treatment has started as you can tell
for two patients we attract that big
vertically decline or TB antigens
peptide in their blood so and two months
later we confirmed we use the counter
and confirmed there these two patients
has been fully recovered then we got
more samples from the our Texas local
collaborators and then they contribute a
lot of adult patients samples best
longitudinal collection and in the most
of patients we we attack the bird
o'clock at very clear decline for these
two antigens and if you look at if you
look at the equations which number is 2
0 0 2 0 2 a 2 and the second on the
psych in the line were a doubt and you
see that the the the single no for
peptide increase at at the end actually
it has the patients with TB records so
we capture that this is TB recurrence
three months earlier than their culture
confirmation then we further got the
contribution from the South Africa
collaborators they contribute us 12
pediatric patients with 92t no sample
collection so we also see the very clear
declines in these patients then another
Chinese hospitals were nice the course
actives study for us there can't they're
collecting the patient samples over the
treatment more frequently and everything
based so they collected that blood
sample and we tested them and the most
of patients is showing the very sharp
decline over the treatment which means
this message could be monitored or the
treatment or advocacy
could it be the timely monitor of the
treatment advocacy so we of course we're
still looking for the new collaborators
to joining us and to confirm this man
and function as the indicator right
clear indicator or treatment attica's
evaluation so the highlighter for this
attract analogy is it's totally
different from the traditional concept
and we're not reliable bacterial
isolation and but the purity capturing
work quantifying the PV antigens in the
blood and the central amount were using
is a teeny it's a pretty teeny tiny it's
like a 100 micrometer and by combining
minor technology and on a speck and we
can reach the very decent sensitivity
and the specificity and a time-saving
so compared to four to eight weeks
without a final result and our result
our master two can output four hours
sample to answer turn a long time and
the budget half Maui Maui Thomas backer
were using it has might be used in the
communica labs and of course the nano
disc we are fabricating in the lab can
be easily still up because they securely
rely on the current available currently
available silicon technology how we make
the semiconductor and that's the master
that's all the master we're using to
fabricate the nano disk so the paper or
this master that has been published
recently on the pas so if you have a
interest you can check it out so and
also we also concerned the patients in
the resource of limited area so one of
our H brunt supporting us to integrate
our nine of nanotechnology plan firm
with so shoebox-sized the mass spec so
now we're working hard with the team at
their Purdue and they're developing
their they're developing the the the
part of a mass spec and we we got some
pretty more data already so the next
topic we like to discuss is the axis own
so they're also showing them
the nanotechnology in identifying the
tumor derived extracellular vesicle in
the blood for early detection of cancer
so this apply this slide is showing how
to access on generate and we have that
they generate in the cell whence the
accident touched the cell membrane and
the future in fact will push the axon
out of the cell sorry out of the cell so
then they have a lot of a chance to blow
into the circulation and so and here is
the paper very famous and in the axis on
the field published in the 2015 and the
deities there Diamond Street the
potential application of axis own as the
in the as an indicator for early
detection of cancer so they described to
be when the tumor cell is still in the
primary stated status and at a secret
access um and a human right the axis
will will blow in the certain direction
and they generally want to go to the
organ which will be my past metastasis
in the future so that actually trigger
of idea we can capture tumor derived EXO
some in the blood and that we can have
really serve the early detection of the
cancer or metastasis so that and also
the axis own as the biomarker resources
they have a several other advantage the
number one is it's pretty robust to
compare to other small molecules in the
in the circulation and because they have
the membrane protected the content in
axis own and at number two and that's
the amount of exertion
because the cells keep ourself secreting
axis on all time so then the amount of
axis ohm will secure the diagnostic of
power if we have a son
we have a some master to specifically
capture the tumor arrived at Ike's
awesome
so butter their system and limitation
for the current technology for X or some
isolation in the deep action and it's
the number one it's not as very specific
and there is no master yet to capture
this best the pathogen specific axis own
and then number two is number two is a
time consuming January we need to at
least 24 hours of isolation in the
profile because the axis of actual
isolation is really take time and also
they required the required that outer
center field which is a very expensive
and not available for all its research
lab and a simple intensive is probably
not a big big issue for the clinical map
but it's still a big big problem or
animal model because the for the current
technology they need about 200 to 500
micrometer for axis emancipation it's
another for little mouse but because
generally the little mouse can only
offer one new serum or plasma so based
on to address all is a problem and we we
generated the very simple idea and the
first three we we conjugate some anybody
on the Colossus night and there is
anybody target the axis on a specific
number 13 so then we applied one
micrometers human serum on the glasses
site so in this step the anybody
conjugated on the Colossus site will
immobilize the general axis on first
after washing and then we applied
another two different type of
nanoparticles and there's two different
nanoparticles different in shape
one is men of severe and the other one
is men or not so each of them will be
conjugated with the different men
anybody's one can target another I saw
some specific remember 13 and that the
other one could be conjugate a continent
with the pathogen specific specific
remember and perking on the axis own so
why we want to use the two different
type of a nanoparticle because - appear
under the dark field microscope is
showing the green color and a nine or
raw is showing the right color and only
one they conjugate on the axis on
because axis one has a very unique size
size range is about 15 nanometer to 100
nanometer and only two particle
conjugate on the axis on and they will
generate the plasmonics in fact under
the dark field microscope called
leading the color change from the right
from the right and orange yellow and
also the dramatic increase of intensity
so they can easily have they can easily
help us to differentiate the president
arrived axis from the general axis own
so that the scanning electronic
microscope is showing we can
successfully conjugate the two different
of nanoparticles and exosomes so this is
slide is showing the comparison of our
technology with the traditional
Eliza message the penalty as you can
tell from the penalty and the black
curve that's from our measured and
showing a very linear
standard occur and with the much lower
detection limit and it's about a 1000
times more the lower
detection limit come prior to the curve
currently Liza my search and at this
table is showing more information and
you we we don't have to we'll use the
isolation stem so this actually can
dramatically reduce the Sen go to answer
time so using the Eliza we probably need
to add a but or our mastered in less
than five hours and also the simple
amount and
we don't have to use hundreds of the
micrometer only one micrometer is a
sufficient for our optical attraction
and so then we Turkey down the disease
the the disease we've heard we we target
for this time is a pan granny cancer so
we're trying to isolate acts of some
secret from the different type different
type of cancers and we do the cover very
comprehensive proteomics analysis and
eventually we identified yfir a to could
be the pancreatic cancer specific number
and biomarker on axis on secreted from
the products pancreatic tumors so here
is some criteria we set up report by
democracy of action number one it has to
be show that a very at the bridge
difference for axis on secreted from the
parent cancer from other cancers and
other disease controls and the number
two number two it has to be the membrane
protein so that they could be the target
or other message and a number three they
got to be the mocker highly related with
the tumor progression so once we select
the III to we with we investigated the
specificity of this combination so if we
combine the city nine t32 and I said II
81 anybody's in our system so we can see
the very clear differential nation
between the pure between the axis and
secret from the tumor cell and I was
from and the the pancreas cells so as
you as we showed on the panel but life
the site so but if we use this three
general axis and specific number
thirteen
city nice 1863 and the city 81 and you
can you cannot see such a difference so
then we also can include the human
samples to test the specificity of our I
see so in each group in each group and
include the 10 house control 10 patients
waste of pancreatitis and also 10
patients way stronger attic cancer only
using only one we used the combination
was for hu and we can clearly
differentiate
congratu cancer patients from other
controls then we can then we also by
debate if the one micrometer serum
samples can serve the animal models so
yeah so in this is life you can check
out when we used the one micrometers of
serum and we profile 10 grand cancer
secretly to EXO son and you can you can
differentiate the mice with humor models
with with tumor injected at 20 days and
20 days after the tumor injected yeah so
then we conducted a greater clinical
cohort for validation so and we bleed
the cancer into two groups and we group
state one in the stage two we call them
early stage of a pancreatic cancer and
also we have a several case from the
stage three
so compared with sub congrat congrat
from the Chinese and also house control
and we see the very community French the
differentiation between the transfer
group and other control group and the
next slide is also showing the
statistical analysis of oh I see
compared to the c99
which is the only biomarker idea
approved for the blast has diplomatic
answer now so the blank occur the black
curve is from unanswered and the red
curve is showing the is showing the
performance of the c99 and also it has
the capability of this IC in evaluating
the treatment ethicacy if we use the
difference of the axis own secret and
Rhonda from the tumor
at baseline and my and two weeks after
the treatment
so using this different and we can
really differentiate the patients with
good response and also the poor response
as showing the panel I and we also see
the the similar perform we also see the
performance of from the c99 and they can
they cannot be compared lee
differentiate the patients good response
and response so the highlight for this
technology is we don't have we don't
have to use the isolation of axis 1 so
it's dramatically saved a time and we
use the teeny-tiny Amata but see of a
serum samples as a substrate and it's
pretty fast compared to the ultimen
ditional measured or i saw some
profiling now we actually already
reduced the central to answer time on
fine to 2.5 hours and we also sign up we
also set up a bench dark field
microscope and the marking the specific
program and make which allowed automated
operation and so the paper was published
that the study was published at the
nature of biomedical engineering at the
beginning of this year okay you have
increased rate and also you know some
study can not only apply to congr and
cancer study or any other study so the
bacterial also secret a gruesome so we
come back to the t v-- study so the
reason today we also identify the
specific biomarker on axis on membrane
for PP for bacterial diagnosis and then
we think about how we're going to apply
this technology to serve the more
population in the resource limited area
so our post out about with the new
technologies they comprise the whole
bench top system bench top of my back
field microscope system i'm my cell
phone so that's real wonderful care
device and so we really like to
appreciate the our funding resource and
so they actually gave us the great
support for our project and also
collaborators from the work white and
our idea is actually come from them and
the last slide and we like to emphasize
and we'd like to position ourselves as
medical engineer as a supporting role so
the leading role is always the
combinations were biologists so we will
see how we can utilize our background
and the technology to serve you guys to
achieve that goal and a better serve the
patients so that's all we like to
present today so welcome to our
questions
Thank You dr. Tony who for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button to let us know
if or just click on the Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation when
they would type your question into the
box that appears on your screen and
click on the send button
what answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is why is diagnosis of
TV's so difficult with current
technology because currently technology
is always a based on similar concept
which is a file of the bacteria so and
but we know for a certain number of
patients it's about a win certain
population
you can never detect any bacteria in
their sputum and so that including the
extra primary TB impacted patients HIV
infected patients and also the most
pediatric patients so using the current
technology like the culture or smear or
the genic even the gene expert so we
cannot offer a very very good
sensitivity diagnosis sensitivity in
this population
thank you for that answer
our next question is what are their
priorities for TV diagnosis okay as a
show in this light and there's three
priorities for TB diagnosis number one
we don't want to wait to or to eight
weeks to that final result because the
TB is are boring infection disease you
want to quickly identify the patients
with the active disease and so we're
looking forward mastered which is a very
rapid and also independent of a
bacterial isolation because you involved
the bacterial exhalation which will
which will be the time-consuming
procedure and number two we want to use
the sputum because the sputum only come
from the your pulmonary system so we
cannot use the sputum sample to
sensitivity sensitivity diagnose that
actor hungry
P being impacted patients and also the
HIV creations cannot produce is really
hard for them to produce to spill them
similar for Pediatrics so we're looking
for another mastered use the blood using
blood or urine as a substrate to
diagnose TB and the the last one is that
can we generate a mansard which can
offer quantitative result quantification
result is so important and also the
affirmative in identifying the patients
we as a drug-resistant over the
treatment course so you have a current
master that either is a very low
sensitive or is not it cannot offer the
twenty occasion without yeah
thank you our next question is how does
the nano dysfunction in our method
okay oh nine nine of these have two
functions and a number one
during the enrichment to stop when we
mix the digested human sample solution
with nanoparticle that enlarge the
surface area as I mentioned our nano
particle is nanos Benham Parsa structure
so the nano porous structure can offer
enlarge the surface area so we conjugate
a lot of anybody on it so during the
mixture doing the mixing of the human
sample with particle so we can
efficiently enrich the trackpad target
we want to capture
so the second function is once once we
once we spike the nanoparticle the mass
spec target and push the target into the
internal instrument and it pushed button
start and the laser will shooting from
the mass back will shooting on the
nanoparticles and here nanoparticle will
have a second function which is covered
energy transfer
so the nanopore here will preserve their
summer and energy received from the
laser and a positive energy to the
peptide conjugated on the nanoparticles
so the peptide will might then
eventually be captured by the the
character the actor so there's a lot of
there's definitely more peptide receive
the energy and they can't lie so the
spectrum we show in that light I already
show the difference the difference in
the fighting between use and without
using the nanoparticles so the
sensitivity we can by using the
nanoparticle we can increase the 72
times
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question
our last question is why are the current
technology is difficult to diagnose
pediatric patients with active TB
infected yeah we call the pediatric TB
infection as triple spot in the TB
diagnosis of Bute
we probably include out difficulty for
the TB diagnosis in adults and for
example like like up a strong immune
system and which they cannot produce
where while sputum samples so the
generally the culture past can only a
15% sensitivity for pediatric patients
and also Wednesday and that symptom is a
and specific the sometimes is really
difficult for clinicians to figure out
that TB infection were other bacterial
infection for pediatric patients and
also once there the pediatric creation
got impacted by the MTV bacterial so in
the the the disease Department could be
very fast so it's a very urgent is there
is a very urgent needs or rapid and
accurate diagnosis master to pediatric
TV back to the patients
I would like to once again thank dr.
Tony who knew Bernie's presentation I
would also like to thank black boots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through February of 2017 you'll receive
an email from laberd's letting you know
him this webcast will be available for
replay please share but announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye